[Music]
2018 was a great year for action fans
I've seen a lot of great action films
this year even if there was no new John
wick movie this year contained a slate
of action stars you know and some you
don't hear are the most badass action
stars of 2018
ever since she starred in Kingsman sofia
boutella is making a name for herself as
an action star now you might not have
seen Hotel Artemis in theaters this past
summer but an action scene set in a
hallway it was one of the year's most
memorable besides one move which
required a stunt double the scene was
all her watching Liam Neeson's
transformation from award season
favorite to action star has been so fun
to watch
ever since he uttered that famous threat
and taken I will look for you I will
find you
and I will kill you he's become one of
Hollywood's most reliable action stars
this past January he faced off against
an entire train of henchmen in the
commuter
the rock because of course between
rampage and skyscraper the rock had some
mixed box-office success this year and
yet the man can still make an action
sequence work one of the most memorable
despite being almost entirely CGI is
when he leaps from a crane into the
window of a tall building in skyscraper
would have ever thought that that kid
from the Goonies would grow up into this
Josh Brolin played two big villains on
screen this year he was Thanos in
Avengers infinity war and cable in
Deadpool 2 Thanos is where he really got
to shine the character was made mostly
through CGI but his performance came
through even while wearing that motion
capture suit so while this is what you
saw on screen this is what Robert Downey
jr. and Tom Holland were looking at on
set Josh Brolin is so good as Thanos
that he almost makes you want to root
for the bad guy
The Walking Dead's Danai gurira was one
of the biggest break outs of black
panther to play a KO a [ __ ] two
challahs most loyal general she trained
extensively for a combat heavy
performance one of the marks of a great
action star is not just what weapons you
use but how you can turn anything around
you into a weapon in one of the movie's
most memorable moments she does exactly
that
using a wig
[Applause]
ant-man and the wasp was overshadowed by
two much bigger Marvel releases this
year but it deserves its moment in the
Sun now we all love Paul Rudd he's funny
he's charming and he never ages but
Evangeline Lilly was the true hero of
the movie she got a much more elevated
role in this sequel and she really got
to show off her moves and a few high
stakes fight scenes Lilly is an alum of
Los but we hope she gets a lot more
action roles after this the Marvel
Cinematic Universe really fixed their
ongoing villain problem this year
Michael B Jordan played what I would
argue is the best Marvel movie villain
of all time in black panther he played
kill monger beyond just his fighting
skills it's a really great complex
character Michael B Jordan has had a
really busy year while on set of Black
Panther he was also training for his
role in Creed 2 inheriting the biggest
boxing franchise of all time is not easy
[Music]
once you get a role like Black Panther
there's no turning back no matter how
many times your fans make you do the
Wakanda forever saloon esta chala
chadwick boseman is no ordinary king
this king can run jump fight and even
cling on to the back of cars
Tom Cruise he might seem like the
obvious choice but this one goes without
saying Tom Cruise is always trying to
top himself and ghost Protocol he ran
around the Burj Khalifa in Grogan nation
who told his breath underwater for six
minutes now he really outdid himself in
Mission Possible fallout in this movie
he rode a motorcycle through real
traffic jumped out of a real plane
jumped off a real building and then
broke his ankle for real
the halo jump is really the most
incredible stunt here there was no green
screen at all Tom Cruise trained for
months to get this right and then he
actually jumped out of a plane and
landed somewhere in the desert outside
Abu Dhabi Tom Cruise is a
once-in-a-lifetime performer he'll do
anything for his fans if you've just
jumped out of the plane and not giving
us that epic helicopter chase finale
that would have been enough for us so
there you have it our list of the best
action stars of 2018 did we leave
anybody off was anyone too high up or
too low down on the list let us know in
the comments
[Music]
you